oh hi today's episode of Game life is
another installment in our long-running
series Wow they actually shipped that
here at wired.com one of the things
we're most known for is our annual
vaporware awards in which we celebrate
those possibly imaginary products to get
relentlessly hyped throughout the year
but then just fail to materialize but
some of them actually do make it out in
fact just recently two former pieces of
vapor where the Phantom lap board which
is a keyboard mouse combo that you can
play while sitting on the couch and to
human then xbox 360 RPG actually made it
on the store shelves in fact uh Nate
Nate here is uh he's we had this is a
clever idea he's going to a play to
human using the phantom blackboard the
show today you can actually use a
keyboard to play to human arm then maybe
we can't actually afford a fourth game
life rider Nate I'll try again yeah
you'll try again just it's got to know
how to motivate these kids
I've been following the saga of too
human for a long time now I was a big
big fan of Silicon Knights previous work
eternal darkness on the gamecube and it
was really interested to see what their
take on cybernetically enhanced Norse
gods was going to be like on the xbox
360 um and then they delayed it and
delayed it and delayed it but now it's
finally out and does it live up to the
years of hype well sort of I have mixed
feelings about to human on the one hand
I appreciate the story although I don't
think there's enough of it and I like
what they're trying to do with the
gameplay although I think it needs a lot
of tuning in short to human has more
potential than it does delivery to human
reimagines the pantheon of Norse gods as
a gang of warriors whose powers come not
from magic but from cybernetic
enhancements through cybernetics they
fight to save the human race you play as
Balder he doesn't remember much of
anything about the last few months or so
and you need to find out what happened
between him and the rest of the gods the
gameplay is a blend of action and
role-playing game now it doesn't do
either particularly well you use the
right analog stick to attack all the
enemies that swarm around you and
there's a variety of different moves you
can do my favorite combo is to double
tap the stick to juggle an enemy into
the air then leap up after him and then
press both sticks in his direction to a
fierce attack while he's immobile and
caught in the air all the role-playing
games stuff kind of gets in the way the
combat though as you're playing enemies
drop all kinds of loot like six or seven
different kinds of weapons six or seven
different kinds of armor and this
happens with such regularity the iftar
constantly stop fighting open up the
menu and manually equip Balder with all
the new stuff that you keep finding this
menu is just a little sluggish to
navigate now this would be a minor
problem if you only rarely had to go in
but since you're constantly opening it
up to play dress-up it can become really
frustrating and so can the action now
that I
about it and it's best to humans combat
is fast and furious but just as often
you get pummeled and things become
repetitive well luckily it's impossible
to fail when palter dies which happens a
lot you'll just get regenerated right in
front of the spot where you got carried
off to Valhalla in the first place with
very little penalty you you can't lose
but what really hurts you human is that
it ends long long before its time I was
just coming to grips of the controls I
was getting really into the story and I
wanted to find it was going to happen
next and the game ended I was shocked
when I saw the credits start to roll
after only a little over 10 hours of
gameplay but if you liked your first
trip through to human there is a lot of
replay value you can start a brand new
campaign with your same character
continue to level up continue to collect
new loot and the monsters will scale up
you can also take your character to the
online mode and play with a friend which
I tried out and I kind of liked Silicon
Knights says that to human is a trilogy
I say they should take the second and
the third games they're planning and
smash them together into one lengthy
awesome sequel as for this first entry I
can't give it any more than a 6 out of
10 so our second piece of no longer
vaporware is the Phantom lat board well
actually that's that's only half true
the the real piece of vapor where was
the Phantom video game console which was
going to download pc games to your TV
and was never ever ever going to exist
and people looked at it with a healthy
degree of skepticism but what people
liked was the keyboard and mouse design
that phantom entertainment it kind of
come up with for their console and we've
got it right here they released it so
two wireless USB mouse and keyboard
combo you uh raise the keyboard like
that and your mouse on the surface down
here it's designed to playing video
games on the couch right now the mouse
that we got did not actually work right
I couldn't get a part of it all and I
don't really like it anyway the edges
are kind of rigid and squares so it
hurts to hold and it's a bit short too
so as far as being a good gamer mouse it
probably wouldn't be definitely not I
mean normal traditional gaming mice
they're rounder and smoother so to get I
guess you get it into the palm of your
hands but but you did try to keyboard
the separate mouse essentially and yeah
definitely and you're a lefty so I'm a
lefty yeah and the keyboard swivel so it
doesn't really matter which hand you're
using when it turns all the way around
right yeah I actually turn it completely
around and use it right hand and use it
as a writing and well I guess the
problem with this is because the
keyboard is angling like this it's kind
of hard to use the standard WSAV
controls so you just have to remap your
keys to like Braille and colon or
whatever that is over there right and
that's if you're a left-hander like a
right-hander like me is going to take
this thing so it's good like this and so
now the the WASD keys are going to be
over here it's easier to hit them
because you're on this side of the hand
right because you were doing this would
want to never change it right so I mean
as you know Nate you're a big pc gamer
you play a lot of the keyboard and mouse
style games what do you think it's a
good setup I can't quite figure out why
I'd want to use this I mean the entire
time i was using it i found myself just
wanting to drop acknowledge and mousing
on the couch on my lap or something
which obviously completely defeats the
purpose losing this right I just wish
that they kept the scroll design for
lefties and righties and just paid much
so is he sort of sled out but then that
would have taken about 20 minutes
instead of 66 years yeah well yeah you
could have just sort of taken a piece of
wood and put the keyboard on it put the
mouse on it exam fine they're my god
bill is a need for get your keyboard
your mouth your bag of Cheetos you don't
do you're all set yeah so phantom lap
board doesn't really look up to the hype
no no it doesn't
you